You wouldn't think it'd take very much to
convince someone to direct the latest installment
in the hugely successful Batman film franchise.
But as it turns out, there was one huge reason
Matt Reeves didn't want to take the job — keep
watching to find out what it was.
“And here…we…go.”
The latest reboot featuring DC Comics' famed
Caped Crusader, "The Batman," is hitting theaters
worldwide, finally completing a monumental
task undertaken by writer-director Matt Reeves.
"The Batman," of course, has undergone different
iterations during its arduous production cycle,
which began with filmmaker Zack Snyder's Batman
choice, Ben Affleck, not only starring in
the title role but also writing and directing
the film.
When Affleck left his "Batman" project behind
over personal reasons, the film's studio,
Warner Bros., had to figure out who could
take charge of the project next.
Fostered by celebrated filmmaker J.J.
Abrams on the writer-director's WB series
"Felicity," Matt Reeves' film breakthrough
came at the helm of the Abrams-produced found-footage
monster movie "Cloverfield."
The doors of opportunity swung wide open for
Reeves after the success of that film, which
earned $172 million at the worldwide box office
against a $25 million budget.
This landed the filmmaker such high-profile
gigs as 20th Century Films' "Rise of the Planet
of the Apes" sequels "Dawn of the Planet of
the Apes" and "War for the Planet of the Apes"
in 2014 and 2017, respectively.
Suddenly, Reeves was calling his own shots
as both writer and director of the last two
films in the "Apes" trilogy, which was clearly
the right move for the studio to make, seeing
how the entire trilogy is widely considered
one of the best in modern cinema.
It also gave Reeves the kind of showbiz juice
to make demands on future projects that other
filmmakers might not get to make.
In a new interview with The New York Times,
Reeves said he was in post-production on "War
for the Planet of the Apes" when Warner Bros.
asked him to direct Affleck's version of "The
Batman."
And while Reeves told the outlet that the
iteration of the tale was, quote, "a totally
valid and cool take" on the Dark Knight, it
just wasn't the right story for him to direct.
He said,
"I just didn't know how I would direct that."
"Whoa whoa, take it easy, sweetheart!"
That's right — instead of following in the
footsteps of such revered "Batman" directors
Tim Burton, Christopher Nolan, and Snyder,
Reeves put the studio on ice, declining to
shoot the script they'd sent him.
He recalled to the Times:
"I don't think you're going to want me because
I wouldn't do this.
And then they asked me what I would do.
[...] I said, I'm in the middle of making
this 'Apes' movie so I can't really tell you."
After finishing "War for the Planet of the
Apes," however, Reeves came back to Warner
Bros. with the one condition he needed to
direct the film: He needed to write his own
original script.
The writer-director pitched his ideas for
"The Batman" and began writing the screenplay
in 2017.
After five years and various pandemic-induced
production and release delays, "The Batman,"
starring Robert Pattinson as Batman and Zoe
Kravitz as Catwoman, opened in theaters in
March of 2022.
It's clear from the interviews he's given
that Matt Reeves has the utmost respect for
the character and mythos of Batman.
He didn't want to just go in and make any
old Batman movie.
He wanted to create a definitive Dark Knight
story for a new generation.
As he went on to tell the Times, that involved
taking a novel approach to the Caped Crusader.
"I wanted to fight against any sense that
Batman would remain static.
I wanted the stakes of the story to challenge
him in a way that shook him to his core.
He has to change."
To accomplish that, Reeves had to go darker
than any live-action, feature-length Batman
had gone before.
As Reeves told TIME Magazine,
"I wanted to play on this idea that Batman
is going to unleash on these guys, and there's
a part of you that can't wait to see it."
But Reeves didn't want the same old fight
scenes in his film.
He wanted to go bigger and darker, as he went
on to explain,
"You go to a Batman movie to see that moment.
And then you see it's having a toxic effect.
It makes you get a little unsettled."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.